affaire baring vostok du nom d'une
société cet investissement un tribunal
de moscou vient de rendre son verdict et
a reconnu coupable l'américain michael k
de veille et le français philippe delpal
du détournement de 2,5 milliards de
roubles
la peine n'a toutefois pas encore été
prononcée le précisons tout de suite de
notre cosmos à moscou vera goffman le
tribunal michalski de moscou a reconnu
l'américain michael calvet et le
français philippe delpal coupable de
détournement de 2,5 milliards de roubles
soit 29 millions deux autres le parquet
russe avait requis 5 et 6 ans de prison
avec sursis pour le banquier français
philippe delpal et l'investisseur
américain michael calvet dans l affaire
de détournement de fonds le parquet a en
outre requis de quatre à cinq ans de
prison toujours avec sursis pour l'heure
cinq associés russes qui travaillait
également dans le fonds d'investissement
darim aux stocks dont le fils est delpal
était le directeur financier michael
calvet et philippe delpal avait été
arrêté en 2019 puis par la suite
assigné à résidence dans le cadre d'une
affaire de fraude en octobre 2020 un
accord à l'aimable avait été trouvée sur
le volet commercial de la faire les deux
parties ayant réglé leur différend
commercial
mais la procédure au pénal avait à
l'époque où bien suivi son cours